Freyr might look like a family pet but
she could also be a lifesaver she's one
of three dogs specially trained to sniff
out the lethal mosquito-borne disease
malaria
Freya's nose led her to one of these
brown socks used in a study of over a
hundred children with and without
malaria mosquitoes just like these ones
are responsible for carrying the malaria
parasite and infecting children across
the world including some of those
involved in this study in the Gambia
they were given nylon socks a little bit
like these to where the material was
then split from top to toe and given
some medical detection dogs here in the
UK to see whether they could sniff out
the odor of malaria the success rate was
clear the dog sniffed a hundred and
seventy-five samples and managed to
correctly identify 70% of the socks worn
by malaria positive children and 90% of
the samples without malaria parasites
when you are malaria positive and you
actually have that infection and what
the parasite does is it changes your
body odor so your body odor is the way
that the mosquito is able to detect you
and is able to find you as a blood
source although this research is still
in its early stages
scientists hope eventually these trained
super smeller's could help spot infected
people at ports and airports and help
stop malaria spreading it's finding a
new way to identify people who may not
feel sick but are carrying malaria in
their systems and could therefore pass
it to other people through the bite of a
mosquito
so for countries that have eliminated
it's a really interesting potential new
way that they could protect their
borders and keep their country's malaria
free the race is now on for the next
step seeing if canine companions can
sniff out malaria
not just on socks but directly in humans
themselves if so you could be seeing
more paw patrols with their noses a
quiver on your travels in future
Lorna Shattuck Sky News